insidious the last key is the fourth
film and the insidious franchise and it
is the first weekend of January that
means we have a horror film oh my god
it's January you know what that means
possibly a hidden gem amongst a pile of
trash if the past few years have
anything to say what's going on
Hollywood are you actually trying you're
scaring me so the 4th insidious film
focuses on the character of Elise
portrayed by Lin Shaye once again and
this film takes place before the very
first original insidious film it opens
with a prologue where we learn about her
backstory and eventually we discover
that she has had a very troubled
childhood and her childhood comes back
into play when the man who now lives in
her childhood home calls her as an adult
and says hey something's haunting this
house can you please help so she decides
to go back to this house and confront
all of those memories she hoped would
stay buried
I'm a fan of the insidious franchise I
loved the first one I thought the second
one was pretty good and the third one
was fun they've all gotten increasingly
worse but there has yet to be a Freddy's
revenge or a Halloween resurrection or a
Paranormal Activity ghost dimension
there is not yet an awful entry and I'm
happy to say the last key still is not
an awful entry is it as good as the
first the second no it's about on par
with the third in my opinion and a lot
of the strengths of this movie comes
from the performance by Lin Shaye as
Elise she's always good but this film
entirely focuses on her character so she
gets to shine a lot in this film and she
really does and can I just say it's kind
of awesome that 2018 franchise horror
film is entirely led by a 74 year old
woman how often do you see that that
never happens and I kind of love the
insidious films for that specific reason
despite the pg-13 rating these movies
are not aimed at teenagers necessarily
they can go see it but all of the main
characters and all four of them are
always adults and they always have adult
problems and this film deals with a lot
of really dark which is in line
with this franchise the fact that it's
always about family trauma or some
really abusive past or some kind of
haunted upbringing and this film
definitely stays within that wheelhouse
it's surprisingly a lot more effective
than I expected it to be the opening
prologue is one of the best parts of the
movie where we see young Elise and we
learn about her father and her mother
yes the film definitely relies on jump
scares just as pretty much every film in
the insidious franchise does but most of
the time they're not false scares and
it's usually something that's actually
there that's supposed to be frightening
it's not somebody banging on a door or
some animal that pops out of the bushes
or some like that for the most
part things that go bump in the night
are actually horrifying things and
insidious for there's a really great
sequence inside a pipe with some
suitcases there's a lot of clever scares
in the movie and the director Adam
robitille who made the taking of Deborah
Logan does a pretty good job of helping
this film and making a completely
competent horror movie especially for
the first weekend of January you
automatically go in with lower
expectations and I was left pleasantly
surprised by the fact that this movie
wasn't awful at all now that's not to
say that it's completely flawless the
humor in the insidious franchise has
always been an issue and once again
these two spectral investigator
characters one of whom portrayed by
Leigh Whannell who also wrote this film
and directed the third one the humor
with these characters was at times
physically cringe-worthy sometimes
people say something is cringe-worthy
and that just kind of means they were
like oh that didn't work for me like
there were a few moments where I
actually went like that like that really
didn't work one kissing scene in
particular towards the end of the film
that actually made me grossed out there
are aspects with the third act that feel
very cold together some characters are
introduced and it's meant to be like
this big revelation and it
just doesn't work certain things happen
where you're supposed to feel like wow I
didn't see that coming or wow what a
role reversal and there's just no
feeling behind it the film has some
structure issues where it doesn't quite
feel like you're watching a first second
and third act narrative the opening is
very good and leading into the second
act I was hooked
but it's that second act and the
transition into the third that it feels
very sloppy that combined with the
dreadfully unfunny humor made the last
key on par with the third film in the
franchise the big reveal of the demon
this one was also kind of weak I didn't
really think he was anything all that
special but I'm just surprised that we
are four films into this franchise and
they still have yet to be truly awful
usually by now
the horror franchises are just running
out of steam and I must give a lot of
praise to Lin Shaye because again a 74
year old woman headlines this movie
that's just awesome and she's really
good in the film overall if you're a fan
of the insidious franchise like me I
don't think this film is gonna
disappoint you but if you've never been
on board since the first one this is
definitely not gonna convert you because
there isn't anything new or particularly
fresh in this one I'm gonna give
insidious the last key of B - this film
was far better than I expected it to be
especially for a January movie in the
first weekend of the month which is
generally thought of as Hollywood's
garbage pit so who knows maybe this
January won't be awful
I need something a knock on there we go
let's let's hope guys thank you so much
as always for watching look forward to
my most overlooked and underrated movies
of 2017 I'm gonna post that video this
weekend if you liked this you can click
right here and get steppen eyes
[Music]